نعود الى موضوع الحضانه
والجدل الدائر حولها معنى من القاهره
المحاميه ايمان علي وكذلك معنا من القاهره
المحامي محمد طاهر اهلا بكما ليبدا اولا
مع استاذه ايمان اليوم
لماذا
تغيير هذا القانون
وهذا
التشريع اصبح مثار جدل في الشارع المصري
وحتى يمكن في العالم العربي ايضا البعض
يراه مطلبا لبعض الاخر يراه
شيء لا يجب المساس فيه
اولا السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
مبدئيا كده كان حصل في اليومين اللي فاتوا
ظاهره فرديه من نوعها على هذا الاساس بدا
المجتمع يتكلم فيها طيب احنا دلوقتي
القانون المصري نظم الاجراءات التقاضي
بالنسبه لمسائل احوال الشخصيه في قانون
رقم واحد لسنه 2000 دلوقتي الناس لما جت
تتكلم اعترضت بسبب الحادثه الاخيره اللي
هي ظهرت وهي تعتبر حاله فرديه بسبب الام
اللي هي
ابنها قتلته في اكلت احشائه حضرتك مع
الموضوع ولا ضده لي
لا انا ضد ان الام ازاي ان الام الحضانه
تسقط منها او ما تروحش اوتوماتيك لها لا
انا ضد التعديل مع القانون الحالي ان سن
الحداء له لان الام هي الوحيده اللي هتكون
على الابن
رحيمه انسانه تقدر تعدل له تنظيمه ووقته
غير الاب خالص ولو هنرجع للشريعه
الاسلاميه سيدنا ابو بكر الصديق لما سوق
اللي حصل فرقه بين عمر وزوجته وساعتها قال
له ريقها خيرا لك من شهد العسل
لما اتكلم في موضوع الام والاب فده
بالنسبه للناحيه الدينيه يعني اديني اتكلم
كده اما القانون فهو نظم العلاقه ديت وقال
ان المفروض ان الطفل تسقط عنده الحضانه
بعد سن ال 15 سنه سواء للصغير او للصغيره
للتوصل
هذا نتيجه للتواصل يعني نتيجه او او
استخلاص بانه الافضل للطفل خصوصا في
السنوات الاولى من حياته ان يكون مع امه
اريد ان استطلع رايي استاذ محمد استاذ
محمد انت مع تغيير او اعاده النظر في هذا
القانون وهل تستدعي احداث فرديه تغيير
القاعده نفسها هل يمكن فقط يعني اعاده
النظر او اضافه بند موضوع الفحص الطبي
النفسي بدون تغيير متن القانون نفسه
اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم سعادتك انا
عايز اعدل القانون واحد لسنه 2000 لان انا
ضد هذا القانون ان هذا القانون سلب الرجل
المصري كل حقوقه بما في سعادتك حق الحضانه
مش دائما مش دائما سعادتك انها يعني مثلا
عندنا في القانون الحالي ان الحضانه في سن
الام سعادتك لسن 15 سنه مش في كل الاحوال
بتكون الست كويسه والراجل هو اللي سيء
بمعنى ادق سعادتك كل ما في الامر مثلا
حاله حادثه زي اللي احنا طبعا بصددها الان
من قتل ابنها سعادتك ثم
سلقته ثم اكلته دي طبعا هو اكيد في خلل
استاذ محمد انت انت انت ليه مع التعديل
يعني
الاستاذه ايمان بتقول لك انه والله هذا
هذا شيء يعني القانون حدده
هتغيروا ليه عشان حادثه فرديه حضرتك انا
مع التعديل انا لا انا مع التعديل حضرتك
لان مش في كل الاحوال سعادتك ان الست
بتكون كويسه والراجل هو اللي السيء لا
حضرتك احيانا في امهات بترمي اولادها في
الشوارع وفي الملاجئ عشان تتزوج من اخر
فكل ما في الامر بيبقى الاب حريص سعادتك
على ابنائه اكتر من الام فمش كل الاحوال
سعادتك بتكون الام هي سعادتك الاقرب او
الاحن لاطفالها لا انا عايز اعدل هذا
القانون
باختيار ان القاضي يخير الطفل حتى لو في
سن مبكره بانه هو عايز الاب او الام
بمعرفه لجنه تشكل التضامن الاجتماعي ويتم
سعادتك اختيار الاب او الامه بمعرفه
الصغير حتى لو في سن مبكره لان في السن
المبكره الطفل لا يعرف الكذب من الطبيعي
ان هيروح سعادتك اللي يحس ناحيته بالامان
والحب والحنان طيب خلينا واضح بانه استاذه
ايمان لدينا بالضبط تفضلي علقي على ما
قالوا الاستاذ تعليقا على كلام الاستاذ
محمد في حته ان الطفل يغير ان هو يعيش مع
والده او في سن مبكر هل الطفل لما يكون
عنده خمس سنين يا استاذ محمد او سبع سنين
او 10 سنين او تسعه هو مدرك عقليا ان هو
فين مصلحته هل الطفل بيكون مدرك في الحاله
ديت الافضل ليه الام ولا الاب لا ايوه يا
فندم
لا يا فندم ايوه يا فندم مصلحه الصغير او
الصغيره لان
هيختار بالفطره
وايضا اسمحوا لي ما هو ممكن ايضا كمان ضد
الطفل
لا يختار الام او الاب مثلا وبشكل عام
اليس الاطفال معظمهم خلينا نقول هذه هي
القاعده وما هو غير ذلك استثناء الاطفال
عاده خصوصا في المبكره بيكونوا متعلقين
بيولدتهم اكثر من الوالد بحكم بانه معها
اكثر بشوفوها اكثر والولد منشغل باعماله
وكذا عشان الحمام والرحمه والرعايه
والخدمه والتلذذ بالصبر اما الاب لديه
لديه مسؤوليات غير ذلك وليس له طاقه على
هذا يعني هو مش هيقدر لان هو مكلف ان هو
يخرج ويشتغل ويجيب مصاريف مش هيبقى عنده
طاقه استاذ محمد توافق استاذه ايمان على
هذا الشيء انه انه الاب لا يستطيع لا يا
فندم لا اوافق لان سعادتك في الفتره
الاخيره انتشرت في مصر ان الامهات بتتخلص
من ابنائها سواء بالقتل او الترك في
الشوارع
وليس تطبق على المجتمع جميعا انا ما
بتكلمش بصدد الحاله دي فقط لا غير لكن
عموما سعادتك
لو احنا هنذكر الام اللي بعد اذن معاليك
يا استاذ محمد انا اسفه على المقاطعه ولكن
عايزه اوضح برده للراي العام وللجمهور
وللمشاهد دلوقتي لما حصلت الظاهره بتاعه
الام اللي اكلت ابنها انتوا نسيتوا الاب
اللي رمى ابنه من سنتين من على كوبري
المنصوره ما هو كان اب برده لو هنذكر
امثله
يا فندم بعد اذن حضرتك سعادتك في الفتره
الاخيره يعني انا انا اعتذر منكم انتهى
الوقت مع كامل الاحترام مع كامل الاحترام
لوجهتين النظر يعني ما راح نقدر بالتالي
نلم بهذا الموضوع بصوره لكن احنا سلطنا
الضوء شكرا للمحامي محمد طاهر من القاهره
وكذلك الشكر موصول للمحاميه ايمان علي
شكرا شكرا على وجهات نظركم لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقص
ص راب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات